this is from the new york post it says
it is a
horrific story
but there's
an important point to be made in
relation to it so i'm going to read some
of this story to you
a california mom has been convicted of
pushing her seven-month-old son to his
death from the fourth story
of a hospital parking garage according
to prosecutors
sonia hermosillo of 41 was found guilty
wednesday of one felony account of first
degree murder and one felony account of
assault on a child causing death the
jury will determine whether the mom was
legally sane when she sent
no medina junior plunging to his death
at the children's hospital of orange
county
hermosillo allegedly suffered from
mental health issues after the birth of
the boy who has received treatment for
medical issues such as congenital
muscular
torticolis it's a condition in which an
infant holds his or he her head tilted
to one side
um prosecutor
of the case said he was sick and his
mother didn't want him she made a
cold-hearted decision to kill her child
prosecutors allege that her hermesio
drove to the hospital on a day that the
boy didn't have an appointment
then took off the helmet he was wearing
and pushed him off the garage
the d.a said hermesa then walked into
inside the hospital validated her
parking
and drove away
the boy died
two days after the fall so he suffered
immensely
for two days and then died
in her police interview she allegedly
told the police that she had hate
resentment and anger toward the boy
because he's sick
and that's why she killed him
if found legally saying she could she
could face 25 years to life in prison
well 25 years would be yet another
enormous injustice let's
obviously
what this woman did is uh is the word
monstrous doesn't come close to
capturing it
this should be a a death penalty
situation
which is not going to be in california
but it should be
[Music]
i personally would be in favor of
you convict her in a court of law
legally
pass down the sentence and if i was the
judge and it was a legal option the
sentence would be
we're going to take you up to the 10th
story or the 20th story of this building
and toss you out and that's going to be
your penalty that's your that's your
method of execution
that to me would be justice
and and i got news for you i don't care
if you're legally sane or not
that makes no difference
you may you you did something
horrifically evil and you will suffer
the consequences for it and we're not
going to keep you around
why
why should we
yeah i i i just i don't buy it
at all
most of these insanity please i don't
buy it
you know what an actual insane person
who doesn't know what they're doing
that is uh that's like someone those
people you know who those people are
because they don't have homes and they
don't drive cars
and um and they don't function in
society at all you find them sitting on
the side of the road on the sidewalk
talking to themselves okay those are the
insane people who really don't know
what's happening they don't know what
they're doing
those are the people who if they commit
a horrific crime
they should still go to prison
but
maybe the insanity aspect comes into
play because they are they literally
have no grasp on reality whatsoever
but if you have someone who's basically
functioning in society
um and is showing some knowledge that
that what they did was wrong then that's
i i don't care about their mental health
problems
they knew enough and should suffer the
consequences
all that being said
let's think about this for a second
seven month old son
was murdered why was he murdered because
the because he was had had suffered
physical disabilities
and the mother was a
selfish monstrous sociopath and didn't
want to take care
and hated him for the way that he was
infringing on her lifestyle
and so she killed him
now let's consider the fact that take
this exact same boy
turn the clock back by seven months
and if this mother
had killed him for the exact same reason
she would not only be going to prison
not only not be going to prison but we
would be told to celebrate her it's not
just that we would be told to sympathize
with the choice in that case but rather
it's it's a celebration we should we
should literally throw a parade for her
she should shout her abortion from the
rooftops
there would be
you know democrats in congress if they
heard about the case
defending her
i mean that would be someone who the
president of the united states would say
is uh maybe she's a hero too
if she had done almost the exact same
thing
granted she would be killing the child
through a different method not throwing
from a roof but um crushing his skull
so in the end it's basically the same
method
to the doing so doing the same thing
to the same child
for the same reason
but only a few months earlier
and magically it goes from a horrific
murder where we all agree that it's
murder and this is a monster and she
should suffer the consequences it goes
from that to
she is a woman exercising her autonomy
she is a powerful and beautiful person
this is a wonderful thing and we should
celebrate that is incoherent that makes
no sense
and sometimes i i hesitate to make
arguments like this
ultimately i do make them because i
think intellectual consistency is so
important
i'm a big fan of intellectual
consistency you figure out what your
principles are what your beliefs are and
you take them to their logical extent
and if what you discover
is that your beliefs and your principles
when taken to their logical extent
lead to horrific things
uh then that should tell you something
about your beliefs and principles maybe
they need to be changed
so that's why i make the argument but
also
i do sort of worry that we're going to
get to the point and i think we probably
will get to the point
where the left will hear an argument
like this and they'll say yeah you're
right actually
why can't why can't a mother kill our
infant
we'll probably get to that point and
when we get there at least you're being
intellectually honest
the results will be terrible and
there'll be even more bloodshed but
you're being intellectually honest
because if you would support killing a
child
a second before he's born
which almost every pro-abortion person
does by the way
they support abortion through all of
pregnancy for any reason that is the
mainstream pro-abortion or quote-unquote
pro-choice position right now
long gone are the days when we talk
about abortion should be safe legal and
rare
well they want it to be legal and they
pretend that they can be safe even
though of course it can't be safe
because by definition in an abortion at
least one person is dying
um
but but rare they don't care about that
anymore
but that's that's that's the fact that
there's there's there is no there is no
substantive
moral difference
between these two things
and you can't say well it's different
because a baby in the womb is dependent
on his mother
because first of all how does dependence
on a person mean that that person can
kill you
let's take that to its logical
conclusion
what about elderly people in nursing
homes
what about people on welfare
who can't take care of themselves and
need the taxpayer i'm a taxpayer can i
just go kill them
they need me they're dependent on me
without my consent
but even more so
little in this infant seven months old
physically disabled was
100 dependent on his mother on her body
on her time on her very life
in fact a baby outside of the womb
and any mother will tell you this a baby
outside of the womb
is um
requires much more from you than a baby
inside the womb
requires more from you in every sense
is even is is
uh
if not more dependent
requires greater sacrifice from you
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content